now present the cinematography Awards
one of the first two names in music
comedy vera-ellen
thank you hello those nominated for the
best achievement in cinematography
black-and-white production par Death of
a Salesman the Stanley Kramer company
Columbia Frank planner the frog men 20th
Century Fox Norbert Roedean a place in
the Sun paramount William C Miller
strangers on a train
Warner Brothers Robert Berks and a
streetcar named desire Charles K Feldman
group productions Warner Brothers
Harry straddling the envelope please the
winner is William C Miller for a place
in the fire
from the audience mr. Mellor is going to
accept for himself it's his first
nomination was also the photographer on
many pictures including blaze of new
Texas women have
and we'll stop at heaven because this
must be heaven for him
thank those of you who have seen the
place from the Sun and that is countless
numbers of you know the magnificence of
mr. Mellors work now then those
nominated for best achievement in
cinematography color production are an
American in Paris metro-goldwyn-mayer
photographed by Alfred gilts ballet
photographed by John Alton David and
Bathsheba 20th Century Fox
Leon Shama Roy Quo Vadis nettle Goldwyn
Mayer Roberts thirties and William V
skal showboat metro-goldwyn-mayer
Charles Rocha and when worlds collide
paramount John F sight and W Howard
dreams envelope the winners are Alfred
gilt and Jonathan for an American in
Paris the evenings addresses the awards
get more
Albert gilts and John Oliver
on stage yes and there are both first
nominations this of course is the double
thrill all the way around the points are
a little bewildered and lost they're
very happy shaking hands and also
grabbing the Oscars and gentlemen thank
you very much indeed I'm very humble
very proud and I'm very proud of the
great team I worked with I wish to thank
mr. Vincent Minelli for his confidence
in Robert thank you
we accidentally John Alton and the first
tremor was mr. gills